CHRIS ELLIOTT: --on to the
next talk on the Cloud
Platform track.
This is actually an amazing
turnout considering the Glass
Dev section is right
across the street.
When I found out I was scheduled
to go right against
the Glass sessions, I was
planning to turn into a small
fireside chat with a few
people, but this
turnout blew me away.
But we have quite a good session
in here planned up in
line for you, so please
don't leave.
I'm glad nobody got up
and ran to the back.
Oh, the Glass session's
happening now?
So without any further ado,
let's get this started.
I remember being a game
developer many years ago, and
I was thinking about
this recently.
And it was really funny because
the hardest thing for
me to find was dedicated game
servers to run my game engine
and test with players.
I would be trolling IRC at late
hours of the night, just
trying to find somebody willing
to host my game and
get 32 friends on it to
really stress test it.
It was extremely hard to find.
And it's interesting
today that that
is no longer a problem.
You have a vast amount of
computing resources available
for building out amazing games,
and now the challenge
is really, how do you create
those games and create them in
a way that's really going to
scale as the number of users
playing your game scales?
And at the end of the day, it
really comes down to building
in a way that when your game
becomes an unexpected
success-- there's just massive
growth, 20 fold
over what you expected--
that you can survive that
onslaught scale and make sure
everyone can get in and have a
really great experience on
your platform.
And that's really what we're
talking about with this
session is how to make
that possible on the
Google Cloud Platform.
So the game plan starts off with
a very high level Compute
Engine and App Engine and
Google Cloud Platform
overview, just highlighting
the fundamental building
blocks that we'll be working
with throughout the session.
Up next is looking at mobile
gaming architecture that
really shows you how all these
pieces fit together to solve a
lot of common problems mobile
developers face when they're
building out games.
And then up next, what better
than to hear it from people
who have done this themselves
and scaled
to a huge user base?
And so some great guys from
FreshPlanet are going to come
up and talk about how they used
this platform to power
their game "SongPop." And then
finally, wrapping it up with a
dedicated game server that
really targets the real time
gaming where you need tens of
thousands of virtual machines
running all of your
game servers.
So that's really what
we have in store
over the next 45 minutes.
So many of you have probably
seen this slide if you
attended the Cloud Platform
keynote, and it really
highlights all of the amazing
technology we've exposed.
And really, it's amazing
how you connect it.
But as a developer, the biggest
challenge is, what do
I need to know here?
What is relevant?
How do all the pieces
connect together?
And furthermore, how do I
augment all these other Google
services, such as the
Play Games that
was announced yesterday?
What value can that
bring to my app?
So what's really interesting and
what continues to blow me
away is just the scale of the
Google Cloud Platform.
We announced that we have over
three million active
applications yesterday
and over 300,000
developers every month.
And just every day, we seem to
run into really amazing game
studios pushing the limits of
the technology in creating
these next generation
gaming experiences.
So this is just a sample of
the game studios that are
building on the platform.
And what's really interesting,
it's a huge spectrum.
You're looking at AAA Studios
all the way down to small
indie studios, and they're all
leveraging the platform to
deliver these next generation
experiences.
And what's even cooler is
it's not just one game.
They really get hooked on App
Engine, and it becomes a way
of building out their games.
They understand the platform,
they know how to scale on
Google, and they trust Google
to scale based on past
experiences they've had.
For example, EA Games has
launched over five games on
the platform from "Tetris"
to "The Simpsons Game" to
"Yahtzee." You don't even
realize what's powering these
games because it just scales
seamlessly as these games take
off and you see all of your
friends playing them.
And another one that really blew
me away was Epic Games.
I had no idea "Infinity Blade
2," the compelling social
features were all powered
by App Engine--
no idea until I was talking to
them at GDC and they mentioned
this, and it's just absolutely
amazing.
And what blew away the most
about this example was the
fact that it was done by mostly
one guy in six weeks.
Could you imagine having to
build out the back end for
"Infinity Blade 2"?
You have six weeks, you're one
guy, and you know that tens of
millions of people are going
to download this game.
That's pressure, and that's
really when they turned to App
Engine because they know and
trust it to scale and deliver
and allow them to really
launch and
have a great success.
They also used it for "Vote!!
The Game" as well.
That was a very timely piece,
but it was also pretty cool.
Check it out as well for
"Infinity Blade" meets
election politics.
And looking at the core
fundamental aspects of
building on the Google
Cloud Platform,
first one is App Engine.
Most people know what this is.
It's been around for five or six
years, and really that is
the Platform as a Service that's
easy to build, easy to
deliver, easy to deploy, and
easy to maintain your
application.
You write it in a language of
your choice that's provided,
and then you can use this
platform to really scale up
with respect to your
user base.
Another real, foundation
building block of gaming
solutions is Compute Engine.
It's looking at that scenario
where you need your own open
and flexible platform to run
any code, any packages, any
software, to run your custom
game engine, to run some large
game engines.
If you want to run NoJS, it
provides that flexibility.
And I'm going to touch a little
bit on really what
we've seen Compute Engine being
great for for developers
and what kind of experiences
they've been having on the
platform with Compute
Engine specifically.
And time and time again, it is
the consistent performance and
the amazing network that has
blown developers away and
pushed their imagination of
what's actually possible on
Cloud Platforms.
Here's just one of them.
Actually, Ed's in the
audience right now.
You can talk to him more about
this, that I didn't just make
this quote up.
So Chrome JAM, you may have
heard about this.
It was a project that was
basically you log in, jam out
with four friends, real time
audio streaming, and it had
extremely tight latency
requirements.
And it wasn't even possible
on some of the other cloud
platforms, but it was possible
on Compute Engine.
So when I got this quote that
your latency's crazy low, pat
the team on the back, definitely
fired it off to the
networking team.
And they love seeing feedback
like this because it really
justifies all the hard work we
put into the technology over
the many, many years.
Also, you may have seen this
MapR Terasort World Record.
The MapR broke the
Terasort World
Record on Compute Engine.
Amazing.
What's really cool about this
for game developers is the
fact that they broke it in a
cloud-based environment, and
the past record was held by
dedicated hardware in their
own data center.
So this really challenges the
expectations as a developer if
you're building out a game.
OK, I need 1,000 servers in the
East Coast to support my
traffic there, 1,000
in Europe.
You can really now leverage the
Cloud Platform and start
to scale up where your
user base is.
And the key message here is if
you tried cloud platforms in
the past for running these game
engines, and they just
haven't been able to scale
or have the latency or
performance you expect, check
our Compute Engine.
You'll be happily surprised.
And this is just one of the many
examples that show how
that performance is delivering
real results.
And finally, it really can be
summed up in a nice, neat
little package with
a little bow.
Kunal from Wizard Ops, they
moved their application over
to Compute Engine and
immediately, they went,
"Everything is just noticeably
faster in the application."
And we're not talking about
going in the logs and seeing
10 milliseconds.
It's actually in the
application, playing the game,
firing off requests, doing all
the actions, everything just
responded quicker, and the
performance blew them away
from what they were expecting
based on past experiences.
So that is Cloud Platform in a
nutshell, and now we're going
to jump into an architecture
that highlights how to piece
together all of those
components.
And with that, we always try
to highlight the key design
requirements a lot of developers
face when building
out these applications.
Firstly, iOS, Android
devices--
and if you're building a game
now, quite often you're
looking at multi-platform.
And the other really big
important thing is being
scalable to millions of users,
but not just being able to hit
a million users, ten million,
100 million users, but scaling
in a way that makes sense so
you're not over and under
provisioned, and you're not
spending a huge amount on
servers when you only
have five players.
And at the end of the day, it's
really about creating an
engaging social game that just
grows virally and gives you
some really great growth.
And actually, FreshPlanet will
talk a bit more about things
they did with that.
And whenever we do one of these
reference architectures,
we love to show an application
that highlights it is really
straightforward to get up to
speed and start running and
piecing together all
these components.
And so with that, we created
a sample application called
Griddler which we're going to
open source very soon, and it
just highlights how you can
build a mobile game very
quickly on the platform.
And so if I switch over
to the overhead.
It works.
So essentially, you
join in this game.
It's an asynchronous-based
mobile real game.
And so you can go there, you
can challenge your friends,
you can play by yourself.
And so if I jump in and I go
to Challenge An Opponent,
you'll see that I only have one
friend, but Greg, he's my
best friend.
We play this game
all of the time.
And so you go in here, and you
challenge him to a game.
So this will basically then
hit App Engine, send off a
push notification
to his device.
And then once he accepts that
device, it'll start a count
down, and we'll be competing
in real time
against this game.
It's kind of unfair because
Greg worked very closely
developing the game and knows
all of the answers to the
riddle, where I've only made
it through the first three.
And so once he accepts the push
notification that makes
it to his device, that should
start, assuming we don't have
any unexpected Wi-Fi challenges
and so forth.
Anything on your device yet?
Well, what you will see--
we'll try one more time.
I don't want to have one of
these mobile demos that goes
down in flames.
We seem to have really bad
experience with doing mobile
demos in Cloud Platform.
Always, the unexpected stuff
happens regardless of how much
you'll test.
But you'll notice that I'm
actually plugged into the
power on the phone, so we learn
from our mistakes very
quickly at Google for anybody
who was at the keynote.
So it looks like the phones in
this room and the wireless
isn't quite working right, so
let's jump into Single Player.
And so this is exactly
what you see.
So you're hitting App Engine,
you're getting requests for
all of the game boards,
and you jump in.
And so you get something like,
what has to be broken before
it can be used?
I know the answer because I've
done this one a few times.
Egg.
Feed me and I live, yet give
me a drink and I die.
Fire.
Let's see.
Where's fire?
Right here.
And so you go through, and
you're competing against your
friend to get the quickest
time, the
highest score, et cetera.
What has four legs but
only one foot?
I didn't know the answer to
this, and I was thinking about
this for 10, 15 minutes.
One of the guys in the back
setting up for all the AV,
they're rock stars.
They figured it out.
We're just setting up here and
out of nowhere, the guy yells,
it's bed, bed!
What are you talking about?
It makes perfect sense, bed.
So that's kind of what we're
looking at here.
But this next one honestly, I
don't know what the answer is.
I really don't answer is, so
we're kind of blocked here
unless anybody has any idea.
I fly straight and on track, I
take off when pulled back.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Arrow.
Is it in the game board?
Oh yeah.
All right, you're a rock star.
What runs and never
gets tired?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Water?
Wow, you guys are rock stars.
There's water.
What kind of tree can you
carry in your hand?
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS ELLIOTT: A palm tree?
I tried palm.
It didn't work before.
Well anyways, it goes
on like this.
We could spend the entire
session doing this.
Show of hands, who wants to do
riddles the entire session, or
who wants to see some
architectures?
OK, there was a surprising
number of hands for riddles,
but it might not be great
for anybody viewing at
home after the fact.
So that's the kind of game we're
looking at, so let's
jump back over to the Mac.
And when building out a game
like that, the core building
block really is the mobile
application, creating your
native application,
iOS, on Android,
whatever devices you want.
And really where the magic
begins is when you connect it
to App Engine.
Cloud Endpoint is an amazing
piece of technology for
creating a RESTful API and
seamlessly connecting your
mobile applications
to your front ends
running on App Engine.
It provides RESTful APIs and
strongly typed libraries for
your devices that make it
very simple to call
that from code natively.
I had the misfortune of having
to do this before Cloud
Endpoints existed, creating
a RESTful API with full
authentication, and it is not
easy to do that, and Cloud
Endpoints makes everyone's
lives a lot easier now.
And so what does that
actually look like?
It really is dead simple to put
together an application
that calls Cloud Endpoints.
You add this annotation to
declare the path you would
like and the variables, and then
you'll see essentially
within App Engine in Java, you
define the function, you
define the variables you're
looking at, and then what will
be generated is this
client library--
for example, shown here
for Android--
that just makes it very
simple to call
gameBackend.sendInvitation,
and that's it.
One of the really cool things
here you may not have noticed
is the fact that we have a user
parameter in App Engine
to use, but there's nothing
we're sending actually from
the client application.
And that's populated
automatically if you need that
for application and making sure
the user is who they say
they are, and you have the full
authentication baked in.
Really, really cool stuff, and
that all uses Google's API
technology.
The other aspect is looking at
pushing notifications out to
the device, such as this
push notification
that I sent to Greg.
And this is really where
Google Cloud Messaging
provides all that functionality,
and you can
even leverage some
of the stuff that
was announced yesterday.
But another thing that's really
cool here is Apple Push
Notification works
from App Engine.
So some people in the room might
have tried this a year
ago and realized it wasn't
possible very quickly.
But now, it is possible because
the socket's API makes
it seamless to integrate Apple
Push Notification Service
directly with App Engine and
call that without much effort
on your end.
And so it really is seamless.
I mean, within App Engine, you
import the required libraries
and so forth.
And then from there, it's the
standard exactly what you'd
expect, the push.Alert, and you
send the device IDs, the
messages, et cetera.
So we actually are going to have
a paper published very
soon to show you how to build
that out on App Engine, and
also a sample application to
give you something to get up
to speed very quickly.
So the only nuances that come
into play here are just
working with Apple Push
Notification Service.
For example, they don't like you
opening many, many socket
connections, so you'd be looking
at using something
like maintaining a socket
connection in the back end
that lives around forever
and doesn't
terminate after every request.
And then you can use mechanisms
like the task
queues to really batch those
up and send them through.
So all the components of App
Engine really provide the
scalable framework to allow you
to scale up to sending out
tens of millions of push
notifications.
And so one of the secret
sauces of App Engine--
one of the many, many
secret sauces.
I mean, it's a delicious thing
full of crazy secret sauces,
but the Datastore, in my
opinion, is one of the biggest
things that really gives App
Engine, makes it a great place
for developers to work.
It's a NoSQL database
that just scales
to ridiculous size.
And when you combine that with
Memcache, you can really scale
up to 80 million users without
having any hiccups at all in
your database layer.
And so with that, for Griddles
for example, all of those game
boards are frequently accessed
and requested, it makes sense
to cache those in Memcache.
I mean, Memcache isn't an
infinite service, and you need
to use it wisely.
But those are being requested
for every single player, and
it's a perfect use case.
However, the Datastore is a
great place to store all of
those user scores, profiles, et
cetera, all of the games,
all of the challenges.
And of course, you'll keep all
of the boards in there long
term and just refresh
them in case the
Memcache gets evicted.
So that's one example of how
you can think about using
Datastore and Memcache when
you're building out these
mobile applications.
And then the other aspect really
is the Tasks Queued,
Schedule Tasks.
These we kind of highlighted
when talking about Apple Push
Notification Service.
And Schedule Task, for example,
would be great if you
want to go through daily and
send out a notification to
anybody who hasn't played the
game in a week just saying,
hey, we have new content.
Would you like to try, or a lot
of these things you see
mobile applications doing.
And up next, a lot of times,
you need to have an online
object store to store video or
pictures or a lot of this rich
content that users expect.
You may have seen this in the
Cloud Platform Overview where
we're storing video on Cloud
Storage, and this is really
straightforward to connect to
App Engine, connect to your
mobile devices, and start
storing all that content here.
And if you're looking at things
like using images, the
Image service is a great way of
rescaling any images a user
uploads so it matches whatever
UI you have set up with your
mobile application.
And finally, Compute Engine.
I mean, it's amazing to be able
to fork out to Compute
Engine any of these batch
processing workloads or any
time you want to run any code
at all that doesn't
necessarily work within App
Engine, and that is really
where Compute Engine is a great
use case in this example
for mobile applications.
Although you want to leverage
App Engine for a lot of the
scalability aspects--
that'll get you up
to speed the quickest--
Compute Engine is there to back
you up when you need to
run your own Linux virtual
machines and custom software
packages and so forth.
The example we really like
to talk about is video
transcoding, for example.
You have videos in the Cloud
Storage, pulling them out,
doing the transcoding,
and putting them
back in Cloud Storage.
And then the Task Queue is
really the key mechanism to
orchestrate that communication
between Compute
Engine and App Engine.
And that is also very
seamless to set up.
I realized during this
presentation, I say "seamless"
many, many times, but it
really is seamless.
Talk to anybody who has built
on the platform and created
these massive games, and they
will echo the exact same sort
of sentiments.
So when you create the instance,
all you have to do
to set up Task Queue is really
straightforward.
You just specify the service
scope to give access to the
Task Queue within
that project.
From there, if you were in the
instance on Compute Engine,
you'll have access to the
metadata with the access token
or to call out like that.
Otherwise, if you're using
things like the Client
Library, it's very seamless to
go in and just one line of
code, to configure that, and
then from there, you can start
calling Task Queue and
can perform a lot
of operations there.
And those operations are similar
to what you'd expect.
I mean, you can pull a lease
down on a task, do a bunch of
processing work, and then
delete that task once
everything's completed.
And one of those completion
steps might include putting
another task back on the queue
where App Engine can be
pulling that information back
down and doing some more
processing, notifying
the user, et cetera.
And finally, if you're looking
at things like autoscaling,
the Task Queue Stats
is a great place
to go there as well.
So if you see you have 1,000
videos waiting to be
transcoded, increase the
number of instances.
That's just one of the many ways
you can scale on Compute
Engine, and you can really have
the flexibility to tweak
that to whatever kind of
techniques you're familiar
with using.
So the last aspect of the
solution is BigQuery.
BigQuery is absolutely
amazing.
I was talking to a customer a
couple days ago, and they
thought it was voodoo magic
because it's real time
analytics for massive
data sets.
And so they ran a query over
five billion rows, and it
returned in three seconds.
That didn't make any sense
to them at all.
This is impossible.
Something must be wrong.
But actually, it is
working correctly.
It's based on proven, bullet
tested Google technology.
And it's really great
for mobile games.
Almost every studio we talked
to that is building on the
platform and has scaled up
to millions of users uses
BigQuery for getting a lot of
really great insight into
their application.
A great example of how you can
use it is you have every
single action per
user per day.
It's a great opportunity to run
a MapReduce over that job
and aggregate it down
to a level that
you really care about.
For example, total actions per
user per day instead of every
single action.
At that point, you can put it
into BigQuery and start asking
really insightful things, such
as, what happens to users who
stop playing for a week, and
we send them a promotion?
Do they come back?
Or if I have a double experience
weekend, do people
spend more?
Do people play longer?
It's a really powerful component
for getting a lot of
this insight that is key to
building a mobile application.
And finally, you've actually
come to the best Glass session
in my opinion, although I might
be a little bit biased.
When looking at building out
apps on Glass, I mean, you
have the Mirror API, you
can do native Android
applications.
But really, it's the back end
where the magic happens.
When you're creating the next
generation of applications
powered by Glass, Google Cloud
Platform is the best place to
go and build those applications
out because you
can leverage all of
this technology.
And when you only have a couple
of developers with
devices, there's not going to be
a lot of cost, but once it
takes off, you'll be able
to scale up massively.
And so really, you can use
things like Cloud Endpoints,
you can connect it through
Mirror API.
You may have noticed on the
Mirror API, for example, App
Engine is a great place to go
for Java and Python, and so
all of these techniques are
directly applicable to Glass.
So this is really how you build
Glass applications.
All those people on the other
side are in the wrong session.
Don't tell them I said that.
Might not work out too well.
So what better way than to
actually hear about how you
build on a platform and that
it's not just voodoo magic I'm
talking about, that it actually
is possible to create
a very successful application?
I'd like to welcome to the stage
Olivier and Alexis from
FreshPlanet who have built this
amazing game, "SongPop,"
and they're going to tell
you all about it.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
OLIVIER MICHON: So I am Olivier,
and this is Alexis.
We are not yet on Google Glass,
but hopefully soon.
So we are FreshPlanet.
We are a small company, we're
a start-up in New York City
around 20 developers right now,
and we are focusing on
making mobile social
games on app.
Something that sets us apart,
I think, is that we are very
small teams, so we usually have
between three and four
developers per project.
But at the same time, we want to
have a very large scale, so
lots and lots of users, so we
have to be very efficient and
find the right technology that
allows that, and this is one
of the reasons why we use
Google Cloud Platform.
About one year ago, we released
"SongPop." I don't
know if you guys have
played it a little.
We wrote a few months ago a blog
post on the Google Cloud
Blog, and Chris was nice enough
to invite us to share a
bit more detail with you.
So for those of you who don't
know, "SongPop" is a very
simple game.
At its heart, it's really you
have five song samples that
get streamed to you.
You have to guess either the
song title or the artist.
This is on iOS, Android,
or on the web.
The twist to it is that it's
purely muliplayer.
You never play alone.
You're always competing
against someone else.
It can be a stranger or
one of your friends.
I think we did something right
with this game because this is
what our growth looks like.
We did absolutely no
marketing at all.
And this is a million
daily active users.
We released around
May of last year.
By June, we were already at two
million daily active users
with a curve that looks like the
famous hockey stick, only
it keeps growing and growing as
we reach more users across
many different countries.
We plateaued around September of
last year with five million
daily active users, and at this
time, we were the first
game in the App Stores in many
countries including the US,
the UK, and Australia.
In terms of scale, what it
represents when you're at this
point, it's 300 million
requests a day on your
infrastructure.
It's three billion Datastore
operations per day.
We were streaming around 20
terabytes a day of songs and
album covers for the music.
So let's dig a bit and see how
we structure that and which of
the Google Cloud products we
used to reach this scale.
On the left, you can see that we
have those three different
clients that we support, so
iOS, Android, the web.
They're all talking to our App
Engine back end written in
Python with the same
simple JSON API.
Then they fetch all the media
contents, so the song samples
and the album cover on
Google Cloud Storage.
And we have to push data back
to our users when we release
new playlists, when we think
they might be interested, when
they have a new challenge.
We also have a chat enabled in
the game so when you receive a
new message.
For that, we use Google Cloud
Messaging for Android.
We use Apple Push Notification
with Socket.
We use a channel
API on the web.
We integrate deeply with
Facebook for friend requests
on all of the API.
But really at the centerpiece
of it all is our App Engine
code written in Python, and
it integrates with all the
different pieces of the
Cloud Platform--
the Datastore, Memcache, Task
Queue, we use all of that.
So let's see what kind of logic
we have to run because
at first, it seems like a very
simple game somewhat, but I
think we do a few interesting
things.
On the left, you can
see the matching.
So you can, of course, challenge
an opponent on
Facebook with username and
email, but we manage to run
more interesting queries
on App Engine.
For instance, we have a feature
called Best Match.
What it does, it's going to try
to find an opponent for
you that wants to play with
strangers, that's currently
active, that's close to
you geographically--
so we look at the state and
even the city level--
and then we match you on your
music taste because you will
have a way better experience if
you play with someone that
likes the same kind of music
because you're going to go
back and forth with music
you both like.
So it was very important.
After we released this feature,
we looked at the
metrics, and it was very
beneficial for us compared to
just random matching
to take user
music tastes into account.
Those kind of things can run on
App Engine even if they are
very complicated.
On top, we also have lots of
Playlists to manage and lots
of quizzes to generate.
We have to create hundreds of
playlists with up to 500 songs
each, and when you generate a
playlist, we have to take into
account you as a player and your
skills in this playlist,
but also the person that's
going to receive it.
Based on that, we have to
balance and pick the right set
of songs that we want.
But I think the most interesting
part is the
[INAUDIBLE] button because most
games, their results are
on one user in terms of data,
in terms of scalability.
But SongPop is different because
it's purely one versus
one, so most of our data
is between two users.
It's what we call the Player
versus Player, or PvP.
It means that our database is
really a graph structure, and
so we store the current quiz
there, we store a bunch of
stats on your histories of
scores and playlists sent.
We store the Chat messages.
So it's a bit of particularity
and we are pretty heavy users
of the back end, both in terms
of data and logic.
But to dig even deeper on that,
I'm going to let Alexis
talk about it.
ALEXIS HANICOTTE: So let's first
start with how we define
our models.
That's pretty straightforward.
We have our user model that
holds the list of playlists he
has purchased.
Then our playlist model, that is
just a collection of songs.
Then the song model, that
belongs to an album that is
from an artist.
Then we have this PvP model
that represent the link
between the user and
the opponent.
This holds the current state of
the game and the history of
the interaction between
the two users.
In Google App Engine,
this translates
directly into the code.
For instance, we have to write
a Playlist class with all the
properties we want on it and
the type we want for these
properties.
And that's all you need to do.
Then App Engine will create the
necessary entries into the
Datastore as soon as you
start using this class.
I would like to go further and
show what is the real code you
actually need to write on App
Engine from when the request
hits your back end to when you
can deliver the response.
To do that, we can do it with a
real example from "SongPop"
that we call user/data.
This handler is used to keep the
device up to date, so it's
called every time the user opens
the application or goes
back to this main screen.
And we have to pull all the
active games he has, so it can
be up to 80 games, and this is
called many times for each
user session.
So that's a critical
call for us.
If it fails, the user can no
longer see what he can play.
So what we really have to do
is we query for the games,
that is, all PvP models.
And for each PvP, we have to
retrace the playlists linked
to the current quiz and
the user model and
his opponent profile.
We structure it this way.
So first, we fetch the current
user, then we query for the
list of games.
Then we can extract the playlist
we need from the
games and the user and get
the opponent's data.
Finally, we combine and format
everything and send that back
to the client.
So I will show you, for each
of these steps, how we
implemented them and why
is it efficient.
So let's start with getting
the current user.
So we just extract the User ID
from the incoming requests,
and then we use a Python
NDB API to
retrieve the user model.
So by just coding
User.get_by_id.
Why is this efficient?
Well first, it goes through the
Cloud Datastore that is
designed to be highly scalable,
in fact, it's built
on top of BigTable.
That is what Google uses
internally for
some of their products.
But what really makes this line
efficient is that it goes
through a Memcache layer.
So when we call our user/data
handler again, it will
directly fetch the user model
from Memcache, saving us lots
of time and Datastore
operations.
Also a nice feature with NDB is
that the model is added to
the instance memory.
So when you have other parts of
your code that also want to
retrieve this user by
this ID, you will
directly get the model.
You don't have to manage
all of that.
Now that we have the current
user, we can query for the
list of games.
So here is how we write a
query using the NDB API.
You can just do that and it
works, but that would not be
very efficient, and that would
be expensive because this
doesn't make use of Memcache.
Indeed, NDB can't guess when
each was invalidated, so it's
up to you to implement this,
but that's still very easy.
We just define our
own Memcache key.
Look it up in Memcache.
If it's not there, re-perform
a query
and set it into Memcache.
Now that we have the list of
games, we have the keys of the
playlist we need, the keys of
the opponents we want, so we
can just group all of these keys
and perform one single
call to the Datastore to
retrieve all of the models.
Finally, we just have to process
all of this data and
move it into JSON to what we
want to send to the client.
I will just spare
you this code.
So that's it.
We implemented a request
handler, and here is what real
production code looks like.
It's about 40 lines of code
to implement this
and optimize this.
And this has run billions
of times serving
over 80 million users.
So once we have this code ready,
all we have to do is
hit Deploy and let App
Engine do its work.
It will create the necessary
entries into the Datastore, it
will spawn the necessary
instances as
your traffic grows.
So just sit and watch your
app scale effortlessly.
Here are a few more things
I would like to share,
especially with App
Engine developers.
One of these is make use of
Memcache wisely because you
will be allocated more space as
your app grows, but that's
still limited.
So if you put everything in it,
you will find that it's no
longer efficient when
you reach really
high traffic limits.
One other thing is that you
should really only index what
you really need to query
on your models.
By default, everything is
indexed, and that's very
convenient.
But if your models are often
updated, that will be really
expensive, and that
will significantly
increase your bill.
That's just an easy thing to
do, unindex what you don't
need to query.
Then don't worry about
documented quotas on the limit
about App Engine, because they
are just there to make sure
one single app doesn't
abuse any resources.
But actually, for "SongPop,"
most of them have been
increased more than
tenfold for us.
So App Engine can really scale
more than the limits that are
documented.
Finally, we were pleasantly
surprised with the support we
got with the Premier Accounts.
You get to talk with qualified
people that are responsive,
and they really give you useful
insights about what is
going on in your application.
So that was for the
technical part.
Olivier can continue.
OLIVIER MICHON: So to conclude,
I would like to say
that App Engine really
allowed us to scale.
Scale to us, it's not really
about not having to worry
about hardware.
We expect a lot more.
When we worked on "SongPop,"
we worked less than three
months on it with our
own two developers.
We released it on iOS, Android,
and the web, so we
were on a very tight schedule,
and we had no idea if it was
going to succeed or not.
But scaling means that it is
very important to us that we
write a line of code the same
way if it's going to get
executed 10 times or 10 billion
times, like Alexis
showed you.
Because once we release
"SongPop," it's when things
really start for us.
We're not shipping a
box and move on.
We are shipping a first version
of our game, but it's
more of a service.
And actually, most of the
efforts we put into SongPop
were after the launch.
So it's very important, if you
want to keep your audience
engaged, to release features
and features.
Alexis here wrote most of the
back end code all by himself,
and when we started scaling to
five million users, he was not
worried about [INAUDIBLE] the
database or things like that.
He was worried about the new
features that we wanted to
implement to really keep the
momentum of our game.
So this is what scaling means
to us, and I think it's very
important for small
teams like us.
Now I would like to mention
something about cost, because
I think a lot of developers can
be worried about cost on
App Engine because it has a
very different structure
compared to what you
see elsewhere.
But I want to tell you that even
for a game like us with
more than 80 million people, and
we give the game for free
to all of our users, we still
manage to make a profit.
App Engine is not a prohibitive
cost at all.
In terms of cost to us, it's
more of the cost of the missed
opportunities.
What would have happened
if we had crashed
when we were growing?
What would have happened if we
took six months or 10 months
to deliver a full version
of the game?
So this is really what
cost means to us.
I would like to say one last
thing, one quick example about
scaling with App Engine
with a little example.
Every week in "SongPop," we
reset the score because we
want to give you a chance, if
you lost against your friend
the previous week, to
win the next week.
So what happens is during a
period of time of around five
minutes, we have tens of
millions of push notifications
that are sent to our users
to re-engage them.
It's a great and important way
for us to re-engage them at
this point.
But at the same time, what it
does, it's going to have a
huge impact on our traffic.
And for less than five minutes,
we go from, let's
say, thousands of queries per
second to more than 10,000
query per second
on App Engine.
So it's very important to us
that during this time when we
are re-engaging all of our users
and preparing them for
the next week so they have
a good user experience.
For that, App Engine is perfect
because it autoscales
and it autoscales very fast,
which means that it pumps new
instances very fast because
they are so lightweight.
So we are pretty confident to
say is that App Engine was
very instrumental in the success
of "SongPop," from
fast prototyping to scale
to 8 million users.
Last slide.
We are all day in the Sandbox
with Alexis, so
it's just over there.
Don't hesitate to stop by.
We are very happy to share our
experience and more details
about what we are doing.
Of course, we can take also
questions after this
presentation.
And we have more projects
coming, so we are working on
more things in the next few
weeks and few months, and they
are all going to be powered with
Google Cloud Platform.
And that's it.
I'll let Chris talk.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRIS ELLIOTT: It's absolutely
amazing talking to developers
and hearing these same kind of
stories again and again.
And the fact that it was mainly
one person scaling to
code that executes 11 billion
times without any major
issues, that's absolutely insane
and really highlights
the benefits of the platform.
And it was funny how you guys
threw in the, we are hiring
note, because we see such a
huge demand for App Engine
developers.
If you're a qualified App Engine
developer, please give
us your resume because we have
tons of people that keep
asking us time and time
and time again.
So it's great.
And that saying, code,
deploy, and enjoy.
When I first read it, that's an
absolutely amazing way of
phrasing it.
And so if you see that at next
I/O as more an official
keynote or anything, you'll be
firsthand witnesses to where
the origin of that saying
comes from.
So last is our final reference
architecture, and this is
really dealing with dedicated
game servers on the platform
and harnessing the power
of Compute Engine.
And I play mobile games
all day long.
I realize my boss is here, but
I do play games all day long.
Luckily, it's part of my job.
But when I get home, I sit down,
I boot up my gaming PC,
and I jump in for some real
time, competitive, player
versus player, 64 people
on a battlefield,
all just going crazy.
And that is really the other
side of gaming that you see a
lot of people having a blast
with, and that is directly
what we're targeting with this
reference architecture.
And so it's creating a full
featured game experience that
has all the functionality you
expect, and once again, being
scalable in a way that
makes a lot of sense.
So with that, once again, we
created a sample application,
and this is the sample
application we put together.
You may recognize GRITS from
last I/O if you were here or
watched any of the talks,
and it's essentially an
application to highlight HTML5
player versus player NoJS.
And we took this core outline,
and then we really applied a
lot of the scalability concepts
we're going to talk
to, to the application
to show you exactly
what it looks like.
And so we'll jump over to
a demo real quick here.
So this is what it looks like.
You basically log in, and you're
hitting App Engine, and
you can see a bunch of game
servers that are allocated and
how many people are playing.
From there, you can directly
jump in and do a quick match,
or you can find a game with a
reasonable number of players.
So if I'm brand new, I'm
probably going to want to play
in a small server just I
can pick up the game.
And from there, you'll notice
we're actually no longer on
App Engine.
We're actually at the IP address
of Compute Engine.
Obviously, there's lots of ways
of doing it, but this is
just a very verbose way of
showing you what's actually
happening under the covers.
From there, you jump in, start
a quick game, and all of the
assets will be pulled down
from the server--
so the media, the music,
all of the graphics--
onto the web browser
client here.
And while that's happening-- it
usually takes a little bit
longer up here on stage
on the Wi-Fi--
we also have an admin console
that you can log
into and see here.
And this allows you to start
up a cluster, spin down a
cluster, and it's also a great
place to go to experiment with
autoscaling, which we actually
implemented in here as well.
So after the average load on the
server passes 80%, you'll
end up adding new servers
automatically and spinning up
to handle the number
of players who
keep joining the game.
So if we jump back,
we should be in.
And basically, we're in.
So you respond, and
it's fairly basic.
It's highlighting some cutting
edge web technologies.
I mean, it's developed
by Google.
We don't have a massive team
of AAA developers.
But it kind of highlights
running around, real time
motion, shooting, et cetera.
A bunch of people can
join in and play.
And it's always really funny
after showing this in a
presentation, especially at
Google, usually I look in
afterwards and there's 50 people
playing, even though
there's somebody else up
presenting afterwards.
It's kind of fun to see people
get in and really have fun
with the application.
And so jumping back to the
slides, all of this source
code is actually open sourced as
of two days ago, so you can
go in, pick it up, start playing
with it, and get a
really quick way to start
scaling on the platform with
dedicated game servers.
And swap in whatever you want
to replace the game assets
that we provide.
So with the architecture, the
big difference here when you
look at the devices is it's
no longer mobile devices.
You're looking at
everything from
gaming PCs, to web browser.
It's up to you as a game
developer to really use what
technology makes sense for the
game you're developing and the
players that will be using it.
From that point on to the magic
of Cloud Endpoints,
really connecting to Server
Matchmaking, and this can be
as simple or complex
as you want.
It could be, I want to play
Capture the Flag with people
of reasonable skill nearby, and
have all the matchmaking
logic to make that happen and
return a single IP address to
the client.
Otherwise, you could do things
of just give a large list of
IP addresses in a region and
allow the client to go in, see
which one has a lower latency,
and join whatever map they
choose to play.
That's just one of the many ways
of building it out, and
the key aspect is App Engine
has a scalable component to
really scale up and provide
the technology to power
whatever type of matchmaking
algorithm
you choose to implement.
From there, you saw on GRITS
what we looked at, very
straightforward.
List of IP addresses and
also just Quick Match.
And so from there, this is
really where the magic happens
and where a game developer
should spend the majority of
their time, is really focusing
on creating the core game play
experience that keeps people
riveted on the
edge of their seats.
And so that's really connecting
your game clients
to the over full duplex sockets
to the game engines
running on Compute Engine, and
having that real time gaming,
low latency, all the benefits
of the platform there are
really what power these
type of applications.
And what's really interesting
here as well is as you start
to grow, you can increase
capacity in different regions
and you're not necessarily tied
to being overprovisioned
in an area where it turns out
your game is not as popular.
Next up, going back to App
Engine, a lot of cases you
have in game requests.
So it could be something as
simple as at the end of the
match, you have a bunch of
players, and you want to keep
track of their scores,
kill death ratios, et
cetera, long term.
That's a great place to go,
post it to App Engine.
That can all scale up and keep
track of all of the user
profiles there.
Otherwise, if you're doing
things like a marketplace,
it's a great place to go back
and verify that somebody has
purchased the plus five
sword of greatness.
All of the infrastructure, once
again, can support those
full featured functionality
you'd
expect for in game requests.
Up next, the final component
of the App Engine
implementation here for the
Server Matchmaking is really
the virtual machine
orchestration, so really
scaling up and scaling down as
your player base grows, and
scaling in a way that
makes sense.
So you can even do some more
complex logic that, for
example, if you notice it's
nighttime, all the gamers have
gone to sleep at 5:00 AM and
have a bunch of excess
capacity, it's very
straightforward to then remove
those servers from matchmaking
and terminate them and bring
them back when the players
come back next night.
And with the sub-hour billing
that we announced yesterday as
well, it makes it even easier
to start to build out these
autoscaling algorithms because
you're not worried about
having an instance provisioned
for an hour and being charged
for an hour.
You're only charged for the
minutes that it's actually up
and running, which makes this a
lot easier to implement and
reduce the complexity there.
So we saw this on GRITS, what it
looked like, and it's very
straightforward.
This actually, Admin Console
allows you to play with your
autoscaling algorithms
as well.
So you can go in, jump, set your
load, and then watch the
autoscaling algorithms take
place and scale up the number
of instances running.
And finally, the last bit
really is that MapReduce
dynamic duo between MapReduce
and BigQuery, and using this
powerful technology to get a lot
of insights into what your
players are doing.
And for those of you who have
been taking pictures the
entire time, I feel bad, but
this is the final slide.
I'm not going to add any more
components just to keep
trolling everyone.
And with this, if you're running
game servers and you
have tens of thousands of
instances, which a lot of
these games are scaling up to,
you have a huge amount of game
logs, and that's a great place
to put them in cloud storage
and then run a lot more complex
processing over them
to get those insights you
really need as a game
developer to be successful.
And I kind of lied, actually.
Glass integration, once again,
think about all of these
components, all this cool game
play that is possible.
It works perfectly on the
platform as well.
And actually with Glass, if
anybody in the room creates a
Brick Breaker application,
please let me know.
I've been dying to have Brick
Breaker because that would
actually work perfectly on the
[INAUDIBLE] scrolling forward
and backwards.
So let me know if you
come up with that.
So that really is just the
matchmaking aspect.
And really, it's about creating
a full featured game,
keeping all of the user's
information around, all of
their stats, et cetera, to
having friends, to creating a
marketplace, to creating events,
social engagement, all
of these features that games
really need to be successful
long term, App Engine is a great
place to build out and
augment the functionality.
Just like with FreshPlanet, they
launched, and then they
could quickly iterate, add new
features, and really keep
people engaged.
Those sort of concepts also
apply to this type of
dedicated server
infrastructure.
And so to wrap up, time and time
again, we see that from
small indie developers to AAA
game studios, the Google Cloud
Platform is the place for
cutting edge developers to
build out these really
innovative experiences, and we
continue to see people really
pushing the boundaries and
blowing us away with
what they're
building on the platform.
And the Solution Papers for the
mobile architecture, the
iOS Push Notification, and the
Dedicated Game Server are
already published or will be
published very soon to the
Cloud Platform website.
If you go to the website,
there should
be Resources button.
You can click there, and all
the papers will show up.
Otherwise, keep an eye on the
newsletter for a lot of the
latest up to date information
there.
Otherwise, the sample
applications are all
available on GitHub.
So the GRITS one
is live today.
The Mobile Backend Starter
is ready there as well.
And the mobile gaming one, the
riddle game, if you really
want to know what the last few
riddles are, should be
published pretty soon, and we'll
announce that in the
newsletter as well.
And there's other relevant
I/O sessions as well.
I've gone through and
talked to the teams
building these out.
Today later on, there's
one on mobile,
From Nothing to Nirvana.
And it's a really great example
of how is very easy to
get up and running and start
building out an application
that harnesses the power of App
Engine to really create a
scalable game.
Otherwise tomorrow, the OAuth
talk is a great way to see how
all of these components really
fit together and solve complex
problems, and it is
very seamless.
This is the talk that justifies
how many times I've
been using the word "seamless."
And also, the
10:00 AM talk is really cool.
It's with Game Sys, and they
talk about building out a
massive scalable infrastructure
and how they
really harness the power of
BigQuery to get some really
cool insights.
It's a really good talk.
And yesterday, JAM with
Chrome had a talk.
Really cool, since we had a
quote in the presentation,
highlights one of those cool
things that people are
building out.
And even the slot car racer that
you saw in the keynote as
well, that's Compute Engine,
App Engine, really
highlighting that dedicated
server aspect.
You could talk to Ed as well if
you'd like more information
about that.
And that's really it.
I'd like to invite Alexis and
Olivier back up to the stage,
and we'll take any questions
that you have.
There's microphones on either
side, so please line up.
Otherwise, please fill out the
survey when you leave and
rate, and we'll keep you up to
date on the latest status of
the riddles.
Yeah, question.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I saw you were using cloud
storage BigQuery to store, I
guess, all the game
information.
But why not use Google SQL?
Is it because [INAUDIBLE] scale
the same, in which case,
we need to use either of them?
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Yeah.
So the question is, why aren't
you using Cloud SQL for some
of this analysis and insight?
And that's actually another
perfectly good option that you
can put in there if you really
are familiar with using SQL,
you need a database that
scales and manages.
And if your data sets are
reasonable size, that's great.
The reason we put BigQuery in
here is really, you're looking
at billions and billions and
billions of rows of data.
And once you start to put that
size of data in a managed
service like Cloud SQL, it's
really going to start to break
down because SQL is just not
designed for that kind of data
processing.
Whereas if you read the Dremel
white paper, it's amazing
technology we have that's really
making a possible.
AUDIENCE: So basically, it would
be just a scaling issue?
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Yeah.
It's really being able to get
a lot of big data insight.
I mean, MySQL and big data
usually don't mix frequently.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Yeah,
no problem.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Simon [? Peter ?] from
Quebec City in Canada.
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Cool.
I'm a Canadian as well.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
My question is for the "SongPop"
application.
How do you manage to get
"SongPop" profitable, even
though you make very
heavy usage of
the App Engine platform?
OLIVIER MICHON: So we have
different ways we monetize.
Again, we have some advertising
on the free
version, we have in-app
purchase, and we have these
kind of different things.
I think it's a basic
business model.
But my point was that even
with just an average
monetization for an app,
App Engine cost is not
prohibitive.
You still manage to be
profitable for an app that you
essentially distribute free
for everyone and just put
advertising in it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHRIS ELLIOTT: Cool.
Nobody asked about Google
Play Services?
I even created a slide right
after this one for a segue.
Should have planted
a question.
Well, I'll show you
the slide anyways.
So if you're thinking about
Google Play as well, how that
fits in, it's really kind of
looking at these dimensions.
Flexibility, you have increased
flexibility as you
start to use App Engine and
Compute Engine, you have more
and more freedom to do
anything you want.
But it's much easier to develop
with something like
Play if you're just a front
end mobile developer and
quickly want a leaderboard
or stats.
So the key option is you have
the flexibility to implement
anything you want
on the platform.
And it's up to you as a
developer to choose what tools
best fit your use case, but we
have all of those tools to
enable those next generation
experiences.
So thank you for asking
that question.
All right.
Well thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]